ich habe hier mit quasi jetzt sondern
sonnen aufzug mehr oder weniger
mitgebaut freunde
willkommen
april aller liebe freunde ich habe mich
will mittels command formular 5,1
rausgesucht die ich wirklich alle
innovativ und cool finden und ich weiß
nicht wie man auf solche sachen kommt
aber ihr seid darauf gekommen deswegen
habe ich sie rausgesucht und mir
aufgeschrieben ich würde mich freuen
wenn ihr bis zum ende dran bleibt und
wenn ihr auch einen coolen command fest
dann schaut einfach mal die beschreibung
irgendwo oben den ersten drei zeilen ist
ein link zum formular wir fangen an mit
kommen
übrigens falls ihr euch fragt warum hier
gerade nacht ist bei mir ich habe mir
einfach gedacht sonst gehe ich immer an
seine tests welt das jetzt um eine test
welt wo ich ein paar sachen test ihr
seht überall so ein paar experimente und
ihr seht überall so ein paar komische
tiere rumlaufen oder komische tiere
herum fliegen
eigentlich sieht man gerade gar keine
aber na ja anfangs hatte ich mir gedacht
das ist vielleicht auch mal ganz
interessant dass ihr seht dass ich
einfach eine test welt habe und hier das
ganze leben aufzeichne
der minecraft facts habe ich ja jetzt
gesagt leute wenn ihr bei coop könnte
mir eine welt machen da kam bisher nicht
so coole sachen an also sachen die mir
wirklich gefallen haben weil ich da auch
hohe ansprüche haben wenn ihr allerdings
bock hab mir auch für diese command
sachen hier eine welt zu machen also
irgendwie sowas wie ich stell mir das
vor wie seine bibliothek oder irgendwie
so ein laboratorium oder irgendwie sowas
das wäre richtig fressen mit hellen
farbe und alles mögliche dann könnt ihr
da einfach eine welt machen irgendwo
hoch laden irgendwo posten video vom
machen irgendwie sowas das wird mich auf
jeden fall freuen aber kommen
letztendlich zu dem command nummer eins
der mir zugesandt wurde von bob
unterstrich gamer und zwar ist dieser
command ein banner auf dem kopf man
schreibt einfach schrägstrich replays
item also das was ihr beim kopf habe
wird replays endet die kontraste das bin
ich dann möchte er namen einfügen slot
am ohr hat microsoft banner 1 ist dann
die farbe und wenn ich jetzt enter
drücken idee schon da unten steht es
dort 103 durch ein schwarzes banner
ersetzt und wenn ich jetzt mal 11 5
drücke schwarzbauten kopf könnte
natürlich auch noch den command
dementsprechend modifizieren dass ihr
dann ein banner mit einer anderen idee
bekommt also beispielsweise ein
hellblaues banner oder ein pinkes oder
irgendwie sowas
dann haben wir quasi jetzt hier habe ich
so ein banner auf dem kopf ich weiß
nicht was man das bringt aber das sieht
jetzt endlich immer diese aussehen
ganzen bollywood film wo die immer ihre
köpfe auf den köpfen getragen haben
daran erinnert mich das ein bisschen ist
bisschen verrückt aber man kann sich auf
jeden fall ein banner auf den kopf
setzen mit hilfe eines commands und das
ist command nummer eins und die nächsten
werden auf jeden fall richtig geile
sache die ich euch jetzt vorstelle ist
mega interessant und zwar ist es mit mir
zu gesendet worden von batman das ist
mega dumm dass ich das grab mit sand
mache ich jetzt einfach mal hier mit
diesem was ist das das ist man diesem
pulli poliertem granit mache ich damit
jetzt einfach mal weiter ich komme
überhaupt nicht klar mit den ganzen
neuen glocken jedenfalls müsst ihr hier
eine plattform machen und dann könnt ihr
einen theoretischen plattform vier
blöcke darüber machen oder 20 oder zwei
blöcke darüber das ist komplett egal das
wichtige ist nur dass sicherheit an so
einen knopf neben setzen hier auf knopf
neben und zwar schreibt er beenden
hier ist ein funktionierender auf zu
können wir mal bei f3 schauen seht ihr
schon die zahl in der mitte da links
also diese zahl 69 jetzt 70 und so ist
die zahl wo wir uns gerade befinden also
die y koordinaten das heißt wir geben
tpg und die zahl in der mitte muss
geändert werden das heißt das hier ist
dann nicht 69 sondern weil ich ja vier
blöcke nach unten möchte 69 4 sind
dementsprechend 65 er klickt man dann
einfach mal fertig und hier geben wir
jetzt einfach 69 1 weil wir auf die
plattform da oben wollen das heißt 69
und wenn ich jetzt diesen knopf drücke
werde ich automatisch hier nach oben
teleportiert und wenn ich jetzt einfach
mal diesen knopf drücke bin ich wieder
unten
ich habe hier mit quasi jetzt sollen
sondern aufzug mehr oder weniger mit
gebaut also das ist richtig richtig
coole sache das ist eine extrem simple
sache jeder weiß glaube ich dass man svp
und dann seine koordinaten irgendwie
eingeben kann und dann wird man zu
anderen koordinaten teleportiert aber
dass man das so mit command blogs als
aufzug seht ihr das was gerade recht zum
bildschirm das ist einfach ein
unterwasser tempel freunde ich weiß
nicht woran es liegt
ich denke man sieht wenn man jetzt mal
recht zum bildschirm schaut ich weiß
nicht woran es liegt aber irgendwie
finde ich immer diese scheiss
unterwasser tempel als ob die so mega
selten sind dass das dass ich einfach
immer nur so ein glück hab das kann doch
nicht sein dass ich immer diese unter
wasser tempel hallo kripo aber egal wir
sind hier bei den kommerz und nicht bei
irgendeinem
das sieht vorstellung hab ich eigentlich
wieder bock auf lustig vorstellung ich
fand es eigentlich immer ganz witzig und
ich liebe sie
das ist richtig cool jedenfalls kamel
der batman quasi der ist auf jeden fall
ganz interessanter kerl und das ist eine
richtig simple idee aber es kann
interessant genutzt werde minecraft
manager und zweifachen aufzug machen und
nicht so blöd immer mit meinen katzen da
muss man sich hoch klicken und übrigens
lasse ich das heute einfach mal alles im
dunkeln weil ich mir gedacht hab da
schießt petkovic ist eine veränderung
und dadurch mögliche eigentlich ist es
nur eine einmalige sache aber wir kommen
zu der sache nummer drei was der gast
schon ein gelände gesehen hat und zwar
wurde es mir zugesendet von luca das ist
nämlich ganz interessant weil die in
person die mir das zu seiner teils luca
und diesen fact diesem command habe ich
schon mal in einer facts folge
drangenommen zwar geht es um diesen
command / kis leerzeichen sp oder oder
oder alt kraft also euren ingame namen
skull 130
das einzige was ihr verändern müsste ist
diese zeile name des spieler bin ich
jetzt hier nämlich beispielsweise mal in
lodz eingeben dann bekomme ich den kopf
von lodz das heißt mit diesem command
ist es quasi möglich dass ihr hier
irgendeinen namen von einem youtuber
welt von minecraft gegen den typen
einfach ein gibt und dann bekommt ihr
einfach den kopf von dieser person das
heißt wenn irgendwann ankündigt halo ich
mache mir neuen skin oder so könnt ihr
da einfach denen den command quasi ein
geben könnte den kopf eingeben
den namen des spielers eingeben das
ruckelt da manchmal ihr seht schon bei
mir ist es jetzt gerade wieder heftig
anrücken weil er einfach online
nachschauen mussten ok welchen
kompletter denn eigentlich und jetzt
habe ich den kopf von bronk
beispielsweise ich kann doch einfach mal
meinen namen eingeben das sollte dann
eigentlich recht schnell gehen weil ich
ja quasi der spieler bin der das hier
gerade hier habe ich jetzt mein kopf von
mir den kann ich sogar hinsetzen mit
maske extrem cool
ihr könnt ihr mir zuhört ein bisschen
hinter die maske gucken da die tiere
sind der maske ist auf jeden fall eine
ganz interessante sache und ja freunde
es muss jetzt nicht wieder jeder in den
kommentaren roswitha ich weiß ich habe
diesen command schon mal als fake
vorgestellt aber ich habe ja gesagt dass
diese commands folge nicht die versetzen
wird sondern dazu zusätzlich in addition
dazu kommt das heißt es kann sein dass
ich teilweise wirklich co man nehme die
schon mal in folge vorgestellt habe
einfach um sie noch mal dieser command
zwar anzunehmen weil ich stelle hier die
commands vor die ich cool finde
und wenn ich die schon mal in folge
gestellt habt dann ist es halt auch so
dass ich sie trotzdem cool finde also
ich weiß dass jeder folge vorgestellt
habe aber ich dachte jetzt einfach von
0,1 folge ist es ganz still ich und das
vakuum hat nummer drei damit zugesandt
wurde von jan luca oder luca p
danke ja whatcha say you say what to do
with the drunken sailor da ich weiß hat
es war gar nichts zu tun mit den bremer
stadtmusikanten aber das ist command
nummer 4 der mir zu gesendet wurde von p
unterstrich flip und transport dieser
code den ihr dem command blog seht die
bremer stadtmusikanten wir hier mal
reinschauen seht ihr schon okay da ist
dann ein wolf der ist geteilt dann haben
wir hier sagten wir ein rätsel ort wir
haben eine kuh und wir haben wir haben
haben wir haben einen ticken war das
genau
und wir haben einen esel fährt ich weiß
nicht wie das leseland ich glaub das war
ein esel wenn wir ganz oben hin schauen
sehen wir sogar stadtmusikanten also das
chicken wurde sogar stadtmusikanten
genannt und das sind einfach so mit
dieser leidigen sache da kann man echt
extrem simple sachen zu machen aber ich
bitte euch wenn ihr mit command zusendet
das habe ich jetzt nur angenommen weil
es zu ganz coole sache jetzt einfach so
stadtmusikanten bremer stadtmusikanten
fresh riding sachen werden mit zu häufen
zugesendet ich hab circa 13.000 sachen
und ankommens die nur mit riding sachen
sind deswegen das wird ein bisschen
eintönig solche anderen commands wie ich
jetzt gerade hatte irgendwie mit den
köpfen kriegen oder mit irgendwelchen
aufzügen machen sind zwar auch simpel
aber das sind coole neue ideen aber wenn
mir dann gesagt wird ja da ist gigant
riding eine spinne und riding ein spyder
und dann hat man einen fliegenden
helikopter denk mir
nee das ist jetzt nicht so kreativ aber
auf jeden fall wurden wir dass die
zugesendet von pe unterstrich flip und
damit kann man die bremer
stadtmusikanten schaffen es ist beim
mega unnötig aber eigentlich ganz fresh
dass das ganze so funktioniert nach das
war auf jeden fall pop nummer für nummer
rofin wurde mir zugesendet von ben und
zwar schreiben ja damit kann man sich
ein glühwürmchen machen und zwar sind
sich jetzt übrigens im merck
wahrscheinlich ich bin nicht mehr bei 60
fps mit am start bei 60 fps dort bei mir
20 minuten länger zu rendern ich weiß es
nicht viel aber ich finde 30 fps also
bei mir läuft flüssig ist wahrscheinlich
jetzt ein bisschen ruhiger geworden weil
30 fps und hat mich so flüssig wie 60
fps aber ich denke 60
für mich einfach unnötig wäre das nur
noch in manchen fällen machen welche
besonderen videos wo man 60 fps benötigt
aber sonst gehen ja auch 30 fps also das
ist jetzt nicht essentiell wichtig für
euch dass ich hier 60 fps hochladen
deswegen bin ich auf jeden fall wieder
bei 30 fps nicht dass ihr euch wohntrend
schreib mir damit kann man glücklich
machen und zwar geben wir das hier
einfach anklicken auf fertig und ihr
seht wonach ich muss allerdings hier
neben setzen da seht ihr schon was darum
fliegt uns war da eine fledermaus die
hat sonnen xp teil an sich ran clay
heften und das leuchtet nämlich sogar
das heißt wenn ich jetzt mal 20.000
mache und jetzt rein theoretisch mal
ganz oft hier sachen bahn setze dir
schon oft noch hier wieder alles auch
ich mal wieder alles kaputt hier seht
ihr schon hier fliegen jetzt extrem
viele glühwürmchen rum
ich finde damit kann man eine welt ganz
cool design und es wäre mega cool wenn
bei irgendwelchen adventure maps oder so
dann kann man ja fledermäuse räume
reinpacken und so kann man jetzt bauen
kann man auch solche sachen auf jeden
fall mal machen das ist ganz cool bei
irgendwelchen dunklen sachen weil ich
halt ein bisschen leucht ein bisschen
licht von sich geben ich denke das sieht
man also das ist jetzt nicht der letzte
sondern dieses ding
und die sieht man halt im dunkeln
deswegen fällig das mega cool wenn man
das bei der die gegen welchen adventure
einfügen würde mit diesem glühwürmchen
also es sind quasi einfach nur
undurchsichtige unsichtbare fledermäuse
die sonne expertenansicht dranhängen
haben das hört man auch mit den songs
aber ich finde an sich ist es eine coole
idee das ganze als glühwürmchen
darzustellen und bei irgendwelchen
adventure maps mega interessant wenn man
da einfach solche sachen mit
implementieren würde ja freuen und damit
war es das jetzt auch schon wieder für
diese folge der command wenn es euch
gefallen hat und ihr den bremer
stadtmusikanten hier einen gefallen tun
möchte und die ganzen glühwürmchen und
so weiter würde ich mich über eine
bewertung freuen wenn ihr mehr von
dieser serie wollt schreibt mir die
kommentare und wenn ihr selber einen
coolen command kennt schaut einfach in
die beschreibung irgendwo über den link
zu meinem mikro und zu später und zu
installieren was macht der kleine typ
der nie etwas macht sein bruder hier
alter wie du sind hier so viele kleine
zombies wir sind ja allgemein so viele
mopses nacht aber nicht gut ich würde
mal wieder rein macht gut und gibt auch
etwas zu sagen was zu sagen was zu sagen
dass da irgendwas war noch wichtig was
ich am meisten vergesst sich sonst als
letzter reißt ihm einfach aber da freuen